Rachel Lindsay and her fiance Brian Abba solo are giving us some serious road trippin goals you guys so it's our be back at it again this time I'm riding B use driving the newly engaged bachelorette couple who have adorably dubbed themselves R & B we're heading out of Houston on Wednesday after being showered with love by Rachel's family and let's just say we wish we could have hit the road with them so at the DJ and I've been taking requests while we're on this road trip again so being keeps asking for music 90s in mm I'm not about that but we're a couple we're all about the compromise the adorable pair did not disappoint Rach taking to Instagram stories to document the entire musical ride the 32 year old Texas native even took a moment to flaunt her new Neil Lane bling and proved her DJ skills are totally on point [Music] put these to be any cuter